Film Courage: Do you think a screenwriter
should write their first draft as quickly
as possible, just regurgitate it out of themselves
and then revise from there?
Pilar Alessandra, Writer and Instructor: Ahh!
You’re talking about the vomit draft aren’t
you, right?
We have such nice expressions for it.
Yes, I do.
And I urge my students not to look back.
That’s where the perfections start to come
in and they stop up their writing process
and they have these beautiful first acts and
then they never go any further.
So yes, by all means, write to the end.
And then you can go back in and you can start
honing in or chiseling away at it, fattening
it up, making it better.
But write to the end.
Film Courage: So if they plan to do a 90-page
script, don’t stop in the middle and make
sure that it’s okay.
They’ve got to just get it all out.
Pilar Alessandra: Right, barrel forward.
I think so many people make the mistake of
going back and rereading what they wrote the
day before and polishing up with what they
wrote and only moving this much further.
We don’t have enough time, you know?
We only set so much writing time a day.
You’ve got to make as much use of that as
you can and press forward.
Film Courage: Is there a timeframe for writing
this first script?
Pilar Alessandra: I think that timeframe is
personal.
It really depends on where you can fit it
in your life.
You know, I’ve made my whole philosophy
of teaching is writing in ten minute increments
because being a busy person myself and knowing
that my writers are busy, so I do believe
that what ever time you can make the best
use of it as long as you focus.